uh james i want to follow up on what
you're saying about marcus's um what was
the phrase you call it repressive
tolerance repressive tolerance because i
find that i'm going to write this down
actually repressive tolerance um when
you they try and basically it sounds
like not eradicate the right but they're
trying to preempt the right by making it
so they don't even whatever that means
the right that they don't even have
thoughts they don't even think the
thoughts what i'm finding is if you try
and destroy part of a dichotomy it's
like a magnet and you have a north and a
south and if you break it in half the
new piece still has a north and a south
so if you eradicate the right you're
essentially creating a new left and a
new right and then you have to eradicate
that right yeah which then creates a new
left and a new right which is ever
smaller yeah and you're ripping society
in half over and over again yeah so he
actually defines what the left is is the
people who want to have a whole new
society in other words a revolution in
other words marxists when does it hold
on hold on hold on there are a minute
good sir i would like a whole new
society
i would like i would like constitutional
uh constitution to be upheld i would
like the the federal reserve to be
you know not i would like uh our our
system of governance to actually be
representative i i would like i would
say that uh i consider myself to be
particularly revolutionary in that our
system is broken in a large variety of
ways and i think most trump supporters
agree with that yeah that's because
it's class consciousness
right the only thing is i don't think we
should be like i don't know burning it
down and killing people not smashing
windows we should be like you know going
through paperwork and being like hey
guys i think this would work better and
then we say all right let's give it
let's give it a shot yeah absolutely so
yeah manga is class consciousness marx
turns out
surprisingly wasn't totally wrong marx
believed that when capitalism
reached an
advanced enough stage when it reached a
late enough stage it would see so much
control and become so corrupt
that eventually the working class would
awaken and realize hey wait
we are being screwed over by the power
elite and we need to seize the means of
production etc
the problem was marx thought what the
working class would want is equity
everybody made equal everything shared
equitably
what it wants is freedom the human
spirit cries to freedom it does not cry
to let's share all of our crap it cries
to freedom he was a really he was not a
smart man marx no not particularly he's
also a very entitled spoiled brat man he
spent down his parents money he spent
down his wife's family's money spent
down engel's money went angles engels
did not marry the we'll say love of his
life i don't know they live together 20
years relationship she dies right
marx writes a letter to angles who's his
cash cow and in this letter he writes a
couple of sentences at the beginning
like oh that's sad i'm sorry to hear
that then he writes 30-something
sentences about his financial problems
and could you send a check to engels
when this love of his life died that's
the letter he sends and so much so that
engels who's basically been like his
little like lap dog on a leash this
whole time is like
oof bro
not even by the way here's your check
because total cuck but um he was not a
good guy he was not a good player but
think about it doesn't he represent the
modern left in so many ways like very
well no exactly
like them the exactly and then they are
just like him right right they are they
are the children of of his entitled and
ignorant and naive ideology that's right
it's it's
when you when you actually
when you think about the universe and
what it takes to to to create and
survive and to maintain you have a very
different worldview but when you're born
into luxury and you don't understand
like
it's it's it i view it as
somebody who understands physics and
they can they understand the building
blocks of reality and physicists tend to
then they have a general understanding
of how things are connected and what you
need to make a certain thing work but
then imagine you have like a fifth grade
science teacher who doesn't know
anything about physics because he's just
got hired for the job and put him in the
science department and he doesn't
understand what he's talking about he's
like i should be able to do this and it
should work and it doesn't he doesn't
understand the underlying principles
that make a machine work when you have
people who are born into luxury they
don't understand the base components of
existence of an economy of hard work of
what made the economy good family
structure for instance so they say well
now that we're floating on top of this
cloud well above where all the worker
bees are
you know what do we want
if you grow up
if you develop your mind without seeing
the hard work required to maintain then
you will not advocate for its
maintenance that's right and that's what
mark's not hard to get food it's just at
the grocery store yep and that's exactly
what people said to me when i criticized
ubi
when they were shutting down these
stores
and uh from covet i actually had a guy
tweet at me i said the dairy farms are
dumping the dairy because they can't get
the processing plants to take it because
the processing plants can't get the
plastic cartons and the cartons aren't
being made the whole economy is sludged
up and then i said so when this all
shuts down where do you get your milk
from and i actually had a guy on twitter
say what do you mean the grocery store
and i said
where does the grocery store get it from
and they said what are you talking about
it's just there
no no that guy had to be messing with
you no no no
you see this is you got to watch out for
that em i just can't even respond to
people like that i feel like they're
messing with me one of the biggest
problems humans have is they assume if i
know it so do you
and that is
most people so this guy's perspective is
i believe it's true that milk is just at
the grocery store
where you get it i'm not going to give
any of these people the benefit out when
they advocate for something like
universal basic income
to an extreme degree i understand
there's some things that we could
probably discuss in terms of that but to
an extreme degree where it's like you
know social distribution of all funding
and when i try to explain it to them
their argument is quite literally ubi
works because the food is just sitting
there and if i had the money i could
have it and then i'm like the money
serves a purpose it lubricates the
economy it is the medium of exchange so
that energy can move from one place to
another without the system in place it
doesn't work and they're just like but
milk is at the grocery store you said
you think there's some value to a ubi or
some some instances i'm saying i don't i
don't want to be absolute on outright
saying
you know in general ubi is impossible
whatever what i'm saying is for the most
part i believe it doesn't work
especially based on what were the way
our society existed unemployment is kind
of like ubi except you have to not work
to get it so it's like so it's not
universal incentivizing people to quit
their jobs or get fired on accident or
whatever so like that's that could be a
form of ubi where you don't have to lose
your job to get it i don't i don't know
about that because by definition if it's
universal basic income it has to go to
everybody including the employed i'm
saying like you know
someone might come with an argument
about something i didn't consider that's
why i try to be completely absolute on
it i think that would be it that would
be right here's an interesting little
aside since we mentioned the world
economic forum and i read the cloud
schwab's books right sorry already clash
schwab z
villain he looks and sounds he's right
everyone knew palpatine was going to be
the emperor it was pretty obvious
hold on maybe he's right the only reason
we don't trust him is because he seems
like a bond villain yeah we were talking
about this earlier let's fake him let's
put a let's put a less bond villainy
looking facebook maybe the anticipation
is this real yes real dude that's not
real it turns out he's dressed like a
sith
he looks like darth vader he looks like
what anakin was wearing when he turns at
the darkness i think they're just
getting bold like hillary clinton
dresses like a dictator and always has
it's a good thing
they either just don't understand how
bad it looks so they're trying to test
the water see what they can get away
with i don't know so hold on hold on i
actually know the explanation for this
outfit but i don't want to tell people
the explanation because it's funny
to not know what it is
it is literally there's some weird
university in europe that gave him a
doctorate and that instead of the normal
doctorate robes that's what they wear
so it's like wow he's like it's academic
regalia in like some sith university of
lithuania or something like that
you know you know what they learned at
that universe you know what they learned
at the university the jedi wouldn't tell
you yeah yeah yeah so so uh who is this
guy tell us about clutch schwab so klaus
rob is the chairman of the world
economic forum the world economic forum
was his brainchild back in the in 1971
he comes up with this idea world
economic forum the idea is to bring big
corporate leaders together with
government leaders with ngo leaders with
other movers and shakers i guess like
greta thunderberg and get them to rub
elbows in massive fancy ski resorts and
these kind of future visionary kind of
how are we going to shape future society
meetings that for very many years were
famously held in davos
for the world economic forum really not
actually at the forum but the peripheral
events oh yeah well
that's him and so he wrote this series
of books his first book which i actually
have not yet read i've only skimmed
through it i have it is called
stakeholder capitalism so his goal is to
shift capitalism out of a shareholder
model into a stakeholder model thanks
for checking out this segment from the
tim cast irl podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
monday through friday at 8 pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the tim cast irl podcast and
there's a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
monday through friday at 8pm and we'll
see you all there
you